all right, let's get into audience questions.
For the week. Very timely. One from Joe. Joe
says, Hey David, I'm glad you're recovering
from surgery. Can you talk about your recent
healthcare experience related
Bernie Sanders and then compare and contrast
both with Americans who are not insured or
under insured? Yes, so listen, I mean there's
a lot here. If you don't, don't know. I recently
had an emergency appendectomy. I missed last
week's Thursday show and some of the Friday
show. Some of the elements of it were, were
taped earlier in the week and uh, I have insurance
and I was in a position where I went into
an emergency room. I actually, I went to urgent
care first and was told I was fine and then
hours later was in an emergency room anyway
and had immediate, you know, cat scan, blood
tests, all of that stuff was scheduled for
surgery. Once it became clear I had appendicitis.
And I'm guessing that part of the reason why
it all just happened was that the hospital,
because it's a network hospital with the network
I'm associated with already had my insurance
information, knew I had insurance and there
were no questions about it.
Now, that being said, I have a silver level
plan here in Massachusetts. It costs me $421
per month and it still has a $2,000 annual
deductible. I believe it's $1,000 deductible
for imaging. So that cat scan, I'm already
been, I've been billed $302 for that cat scan.
I'm anticipating that the remaining 1700 or
so of my deductible will be billed to me.
I don't know in the end what the procedure
will cost. I've read that appendectomies in
the U S can range between 1500 to $180,000
depending on, I don't even know what, which
is crazy in and of itself, but I, I know,
I mean, listen, I have a savings account.
If I'm prepared to have to pay the $2,000
and I know that I might have to, uh, I think
my annual out of pocket maximum is 7,500.
I have that in savings, so I know it's not
going to bankrupt me.
Now, if I were not insured or underinsured,
the circumstances would be different. And
also they would be different if I didn't have
money in savings to self insure against the
maximum annual costs of the plan. Now in the
hospital I had hours during which I was just
looking around, just sitting there and there
are signs that say whether or not you have
insurance, and this is, I think this is Massachusetts
law, but I think most States have something
similar regardless of insurance status or
ability to pay. Uh, I have to be given a stabilizing
treatment and if necessary, a transfer to
another facility. Now if you go in with acute
appendicitis and you don't have insurance,
what counts as stabilizing treatment? The
appendix has to come out or you can try to
treat it in some cases with antibiotics. Although
in my case they said, you know, you really
should have it removed.
Is anything short of an appendectomy considered
stabilizing for someone with acute appendicitis?
I don't know the answer to that. Those are
the types of problems that would ultimately
present themselves for someone who is uninsured
and underinsured by under-insured, I'm guessing
we're talking about a catastrophic plan, which
instead of running for 20 a month, like I
pay, I think it's about half of that. Like
it's still $200 a month. I think, um, what
happens or if you have a subsidized catastrophic
plan where you might, because of your income
only pay $60 a month. But if you go in there,
you might have a $7,000 deductible that has
to be met. What happens? You're screwed basically.
Um, do you go into bankruptcy? I don't know.
Do you go into this debt collection, industrial
complex and then potentially start paying
interest on top of the bills? I mean, this
is why the system doesn't make sense because
as soon as you're in that sort of hamster
treadmill as it is effectively, uh, you, are
you going to be even more hampered in your
ability to get out of it?
Because at that point you have trouble potentially
making your car payment. If your car gets
repossessed. How do you get to work? You need
to go to work in order to make the money to
pay off the medical debt. And you very quickly
start seeing the snowball effect and the negative
externalities of this. So, I mean, listen,
my situation, Bernie's Bernie, I'm sure has
far better health insurance than I have. It's
not good. It's not good when you consider
that, when you don't have that, um, and you
don't have some money saved, which I'm fortunate
enough to have. You are, would I have delayed
even going to urgent care or the emergency
room? I had a $55 copay at urgent care would
ended up, we ended up just sending me home
with appendicitis instead of saying we should
actually do some imaging here. You probably
delay going, which can lead to a burst or
perforated appendix and then it gets much
more expensive.
It's a mess. It's extraordinarily depressing
and, uh, it's just, it's gotta be fixed. This
next question is, I mean, I'm taking it as
a real question, but it is also, I can tell
someone who just doesn't understand what the
hell is going on in the United States.